what happened at first was everybody was
just so afraid like right we were
getting those photos from china and some
videos and stuff like that it was like
this thing is coming to america you know
when is it gonna pop up there was cases
and then you hear that a player in the
nba has it and and you know had spread
it to his teammates and so because of
the way that it was it was portrayed in
the media it was just such a fearful
time i feel like everybody was walking
on eggshells um thinking about when when
they were gonna get it
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
professional basketball player for the
orlando magic and author of the new book
why i stand jonathan isaac welcome to
the reuben report what's up dave man i'm
excited to be here excited to talk to
you let's go
all right let's do it this is sort of
your second time on the reuben report
because uh i was in orlando back in uh
what was it that was end of october and
i was doing this nat con event and i was
like hey jonathan isaac's in orlando
maybe i can drag him on stage and then
you spoke in front of about 500
conservatives that was uh a little odd
for you but you pretty much brought the
house down
it was weird uh you know first time kind
of even i mean outside of like church
but like really speaking in front of
people and then it being you know a
conservative event um it was dope though
you know everybody was great i had a
great time just learning and listening
and getting a chance to talk to you and
kind of just continue to push forward my
message
so let's uh let's start off with some
basketball stuff because you know that
my dream was to be an nba player you
accomplished my dream and you're pretty
good at what i do that's what i said to
you on stage you could be doing the
talking thing for a living uh but uh but
you made it to the nba and we also have
something else in common we both have a
torn acl so that is that has taken you
out for these last two seasons is left
or right knee for you left knee
left knee for me too uh tell me a little
bit about just growing up playing hoops
did you always want to be in the nba did
you think you could make it to the nba
just the challenges there before we get
into the the book specifically
yeah i mean the the book does a great
job of just telling that story of
growing up in bronx new york and playing
at the rec center in the park with my
dad and and there's when i really just
kind of like fell in love with the game
not so much scoring and all that stuff
just the art of watching guys you know
do what they do on the basketball court
i was like man it's so cool to watch
them go left to right and all these
different things but i didn't know
anything about basketball in the grand
scheme of things so nothing about
college nothing about the nba nothing
about conferences there's one story in
the book where i'm getting recruited to
go to to go to college to play ball and
the coach is saying you know do you know
what conference we're in and i'm like
well what's a conference
and i think that really speaks to how
much i didn't even think that it could
be a possibility for me to get to the
nba so it really to me is like a god
thing that i'm here because i i never
believed in it and so yeah i mean i fell
in love with it i
pretty much put everything that i had
into it became the number one player in
the state of florida coming you know
getting out of high school to college
and then you know was the sixth pick to
the orlando magic
did you always have great skills or was
it kind of learned or a little bit of
both
i say all learned really you're like
yeah i'd love to watch the guys on the
on the tv but i could never you know do
anything like that on the court the
first time i got to play on an aau team
they kicked me off the team without even
telling me and that's that's how bad i
was and so uh my ride to practice just
stopped coming uh to pick me up but um
but it was definitely learned like i got
my first coach that really was like
taking an interest in me because of my
size um was bora and he's in the book as
well and you know he was the first one
to teach me the fundamentals and develop
and and from there i kind of it was just
like riding a bike i kind of just you
know because i was watching so much and
and and and you know i found that
passion in liking the way that guys move
that kind of just picked it up and kind
of went from there
were you uh were you tall immediately or
late spurt or what i had i had a decent
um
like like i guess like a journey of a
spurt it wasn't all that one time but i
was always you know more so the biggest
person in my class especially through
the younger years once i got to high
school i was probably
six foot six one my freshman year and
then each each year i i jumped up three
or four inches and then i got to you
know seven foot
who are your heroes basketball heroes
growing up who were the guys that you
were like oh man i want to i want to do
that i want to model it after that you
know i loved kd um you know great
players still but it's different now
being able to play against them but um
but yeah i i love the fact that he was
such a a big player but was a guard
pretty much and so him dirk pg guys that
i watch all the time and i think i watch
katie before every high school game
before every college game um yeah
and tell me about that moment you get
the uh you're at draft night and uh they
say your name and your life changes just
like that yeah it was it was awesome but
for me it was it was it was weird
because everybody else around me seemed
like they knew what was going on like
they were ready for the moment they had
you know what they were gonna do
afterwards they're gonna go party they
were gonna go celebrate with their
families like everyone took it in stride
but for me it was like
like like i don't know what to do so i
kind of just after i got drafted i
walked to a pizza shop down the street
it was in new york um
with my with coach gates who's a big
part of my life and uh one of our eight
my one of my agent's assistants and we
got a pizza and i went back to the hotel
room and
and sent my my parents my family home on
an uber uh and then uh went went in my
rooms it was it was kind of just like a
it was weird i didn't know you know it
just all went by so fast as well
and it must have been pretty sweet for
you as you said you played ball in
florida then to be drafted by orlando
you get to keep it in florida and and
you seem to have a great connection with
the state yeah i love the state of
florida and i've come to appreciate it
more and more especially as the world
has gotten crazier and crazier so um you
know i'm a fan of desantis and what he's
been able to do but um yeah i i love
florida i'm glad that i'm here i feel
like it's a god ordained thing for me to
be here from middle school till now and
uh you know i love the state
all right so let's let's pick it up
right there because you mentioned
desantis and the florida situation and
what put you on on my radar
was it's got to be almost two years ago
now pretty early on into the pandemic
nba was one of the first leagues that
just completely
shut down out of nowhere in some ways it
was it was the first big thing that did
it that then led to so many other
institutions closing down you were one
of the first guys out there that was
like hey
uh can we slow down with some of this or
maybe i don't want to be necessarily
injected with this thing or i'm going to
make some choices for myself etc etc so
first could you just talk a little bit
about what it was like when you were
hearing that things were going to change
and that the league was shutting down
before it got because it would it all
didn't happen at once that the vaccine
stuff started happening a little bit
later than that
so i think um
what happened at first was everybody was
just so afraid like right we were
getting those photos from china and some
videos and stuff like that it was like
this thing is coming to america you know
when is it gonna pop up there was cases
and then you hear that a player in the
nba has it and and you know had spread
it to his teammates and so because of
the way that it was it was portrayed in
the media it was just such a fearful
time i feel like everybody was walking
on eggshells um thinking about when when
they were going to get it and so once
the nba had shut down we had time to
kind of just you know i think we went on
a quarantine really i think right around
that time um at least florida had like a
curfew it wasn't a complete um you know
lockdown but we had a curfew that you
had to be in your house and it was just
a weird time but um you know social
media wasn't a big help because of all
the things that we're spreading and
going around and so i just tried my best
to kind of take a step back and just
watch everything um there was there was
an early
hesitation with me because of the way
that things were being portrayed um it
seemed like everything was so forced and
and and and made to be fearful for
everyone to kind of be running around
like chickens with their head cuts off
so i kind of just took a step back and
said let me watch and then we get to the
bubble and then after that we get to
okay now there's a vaccine on the scene
and that's that's the that's that's that
we get a little later if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell